in his analysis and criticism of racism
in the America in which
african-americans along with with some
allies from other races are struggling
for civil rights particularly in the
south Martin Luther King is going to
treat racism as essentially an arbitrary
and irrational form of inequality and
he's going to spend a lot of time
talking about what the experience of
that is like why is he focusing on that
he wants to dramatize as he's put it he
wants to bring before the public eye
what is actually occurring in the
segregated self in the struggles against
it in the reprisals that are happening
to those who are engaged in in calling
for freedom and justice and equality he
really has his eye on the white
moderates and their calls for you know
law and order and for just allowing time
to take its toll why he's bringing in
all of this is to try to argue
ultimately that the nonviolent action
approach to these matters is the only
one that's truly adequate to dealing
with this he doesn't think that racism
is something that can endure forever in
the form that it's adopted in you know
20th century America and the question is
well what's going to happen instead of
that another way that he's going to put
it is well we're all going to be
extremists so we have to decide what
we're going to be extremists for as well
we'll look at in just a moment let's
talk now about the experiences of racism
that he specifically focuses on in a
letter from a Birmingham jail also to a
certain extent in the I have a dream
speech so he talks about one thing right
off the bat which is physical violence
racism had been not only
you know engaged by physical violence or
embodied by physical violence when
whites are able to attack blacks with
impunity and they have to live in fear
of any sort of reprisal like that
happening they never know when you know
say the the KKK is going to come along
and start burning or pillaging or you
know lynching people but it's also
evident in the fact that that violence
is used against those who protest
against violence so it's sort of like
violence taken to a higher level
violence is there as an ever-present
threat so you know not only is there the
violence of actual lynching going on
still in this in the South but also
police brutality those who are trying to
say hey this is this sort of thing has
to end our encountering a police force
that is you know using pretty extreme
violence against them as well you know
when we talk about turning fire hoses on
people sometimes it's imagine that well
that's just like you know being by a
fire hydrant oh those fire hoses are
high pressure they could knock people
down and break bones and peel skin off
of people's flesh so violence outright
violence is is sort of the naked
expression of racism but there's other
forms of racism that are just as
problematic and just as pervasive that
King is talking about he mentions
economic forms of racism he has this
phrase when you see the vast majority of
your twenty million Negro brothers
smothering in an airtight cage of
poverty in the midst of an affluent
society so you know that's what makes it
particularly galling the fact that you
know in the America that he's writing
about there are jobs available but you
know the jobs will be reserved for white
people a lot of the you know jobs that
are available to African Americans are
the jobs that are not only considered
lower-class but which pay less so it's
more difficult for them to accumulate
you know the capital require
to start a business or to to own their
own home a lot of them were trapped in
economic schemes as we know particularly
in the north in which home ownership was
was something that was dangled in front
of them but also taken away and in the I
have a dream speech King will actually
talk about this as being a problem of
social mobility he says we cannot be
satisfied as long as the Negro's basic
mobility is from a smaller ghetto to a
larger one so you know what's he talking
about there the fact that even if there
is some opportunities opened for
african-americans and there weren't all
that many at that time even if it widens
a bit it's still moving from one you
know smaller ghetto a place of
confinement a place of not being able to
break out of not being able to move up
to a slightly larger one or a slightly
larger one so long as there are still
impediments to as we call it equal
opportunity King says we're going to
have this this problem of racism social
he talks quite a bit about this again
going back to the I have a dream speech
in the line right after that he says we
can never be satisfied as long as our
children are stripped of their adulthood
and robbed of their dignity by science
stating for white only segregation had
an incredible human effect and he talks
about this in a very personal way as
well in a letter from a Birmingham jail
he says when you find your tongue
twisted and your speech stammering as
you explain to your six-year-old
daughter why she can't go to the public
amusement park that has just been
advertised on television and see tears
welling up in her eyes when she's told
that Funtown is closed to colored
children and he goes beyond just the you
know immediate emotional impact of that
itself he talks about a longer more
lasting development of this he says you
see ominous clouds of inferiority
beginning to form in her little mental
sky and you see her beginning to distort
her personality by developing an
unconscious
bitterness towards white people when you
have to concoct an answer for a
five-year-old son who is asking daddy
why do white people treat colored people
so mean when you take a cross-country
drive and find it necessary to sleep
night after night in the corners of your
automobile because no motel will accept
you when you're humiliated day in and
day out by nagging signs reading white
and colored so this this social
segregation imposes an incredible human
toll yeah it'll talk about it in other
places it gives not only an inflated
sense of superiority to the whites who
probably shouldn't have that because
very few of them have the content of
character to pull that off but it gives
a sense of inferiority being constantly
pushed on to African Americans by sign
after sign after sign by going from here
to here to here having the same message
constantly reinforced to them that they
they don't matter
politically this is this is representing
talks about this as one of the forms of
unjust laws by disenfranchisement by
African Americans being excluded from
the voting process through all sorts of
different techniques that were being
used in the South you know from poll
taxes to outright intimidation at voting
booths not allowing people to register
yeah he says that the outcome of all of
this is a it has an effect if it has a
you might say emotional an unconscious
in some cases effect of causing fears
they never know when you know the the
rioters are going to come through and
destroy everything that they've got they
know that the police aren't going to
protect them if that happens it also
produces resentments sort of sense of
you know those people are all bad
they're all trying to a process in part
because they experienced that and he
talks about this pervasive sense of
nobody miss a degenerating sense of
nobody
a real person of being less than human
this is what King says this is the
common experience of those who are
subject to racism this form of
inequality that has no legitimate basis
king by the way is not saying that there
can't be any sort of inequality when
he's talking in the I have a dream
speech about his children being judged
by the content of their character he's
perfectly willing to say that if they
have a bad character call them a bad
person say that you know they can't hold
public office if they're subject to
corruption but it shouldn't be based on
the color of their skin why because that
is completely arbitrary it has nothing
to do with the quality of the person it
has nothing to do with their capacities
it has nothing to do with who they
really are when we look at the the
spectrum of perspectives that are
possible to adopt in this King of course
is arguing for for nonviolent action and
you know we see why he gives you a lot
of argument for that but he also
discusses some of the other
possibilities as well so he I'm going to
come back to the white moderate in just
a moment he talks about those within the
African American community who are
proposing in you know engaging in
violent action and you know everything
ranging from self-defense you know
getting weapons to protect themselves
organizing something like a militia that
would be a response to say the the KKK
all the way to those who are advocating
a kind of domestic terrorism he would
include in their groups like you know
black separatists who are arguing that
blacks and whites could never live in an
integrated society that both have to
look out for themselves
some proposals actually went so far that
yes to say that there should be mass
relocation programs that a portion of
the United States should be set aside
for African Americans and African
Americans would all move there and
everybody else would move out and then
the other portion would be left for
white people and King is saying look
none of that is going to work but that's
where things are headed
if this isn't addressed racism is not
going to go away by itself and if you
don't go along with nonviolent action to
try to address racism and ultimately to
eliminate it then pretty soon this is
going to be the alternative that I get
seen as the effective it won't be just
it won't be loving but it might be
effective for a short time probably not
all that effective but to some degree
and it's something that's attractive and
this is actually a struggle that you see
going on within the civil rights
community King is the representative of
non-violent action other people are the
representatives of violent action of
taking reprisals and what is the source
of this he says that you know this is
this is a force within the African
American community says the other force
is one of bitterness and hatred it's
expressed in these particular groups
nourished by the Negroes frustration
over the continued existence of racial
discrimination this movement has made
made up of people who have lost faith in
America who say look we're never
actually going to get a payment on that
blank check that you're talking about in
me I have a dream speech was actually
coming later the people who are saying
we're never going to get equal treatment
we're never going to get what was
promised to us along with this are the
segregationist whites there are plenty
of whites who are saying hey we like
this system just as it is let's not
change anything let's keep everything in
place and then these two can sort of
square off against each other
we also have other possibilities as well
he talks about the forces of
african-american complacency not only
African Americans were engaging in
violent action or nonviolent action in
fact many of them were saying let's not
rock the boat things are you know okay
or they could actually get much much
much much worse so let's not actually do
anything about it King talks about these
as being made up in current made up in
part of Negros who has a law or as a
result of long years of oppression are
so drained
I put beaten down here so drained of
self respect in the sense of somebody
Ness that they've adjusted to
segregation so some people you know that
sense of nobody this comes to be who
they are they come to accept the
oppression they come to accept the
economic exploitation as just the way
things are going to have to be and they
see no point in trying to struggle
against it there's another group who he
says also are engaged in this and that's
the black middle-class he says that a
few middle-class Negroes because of a
degree of academic and economic security
and because in some ways they profit by
segregation they become insensitive to
the problems of the masses so if you can
be insulated against the effects of
segregation by being part of the power
structure but I say being a token
involved in say a university or you know
being the the one token person in a
police force it becomes very difficult
to identify with those who are oppressed
and to say look they have a legitimate
beef because if you did that then you
would actually have to give up your
you're privileged position and take a
stand for that but where King is really
critical is of the white moderates now
why is he so critical of white moderates
in this this piece that's an interesting
question to ask and the answer to that
is he's not actually going to reach
these guys and he's probably not going
to reach these guys but there is a very
strong chance that
those reading the letter from a
Birmingham jail who fall into the
category of white moderates might
actually hear his argument and say you
know what I've been wrong I have to
change my position on all of this stuff
at this point in time so you know how
does he characterize white moderates he
says that they're too much concerned
with law and order he says that where is
this says I hope the white moderate
would understand that law and order
exists for the purpose of establishing
justice when they fail in this purpose
they become the dams that block the flow
of social progress I hope that the white
moderate would understand that the
present tension in the south is a
necessary phase of the transition from
an obnoxious negative peace in which the
Negro passively accepted as unjust
plight to a substantive and positive
peace in which all men will respect the
dignity and worth of human personality
so he's saying he actually says it at
one point that the white moderates are
in some ways worse than the KKK because
you know where the KKK stands and even
though they're wrong they're not
presenting themselves as if they're
they're really on your side he's saying
you white moderates are not actually on
our side and why not because of this
factor of hi they come on time itself to
somehow change things and why do they do
that they have a mistaken conception of
time because they're not getting this
experience of racism Martin Luther King
says if you'd actually go on and through
these things that's why he's you know
late as he's coming up with a whole list
of these these experiences these core
indignities that African Americans are
subjected to you say to the white
moderate if you actually experienced
that yourself
or you knew people who were experiencing
it
you wouldn't say why can't you wait you
wouldn't be calling for moderation you
wouldn't be saying slow it down you'd
actually be saying let's speed it up and
Kenya has some really interesting things
to say about this he says I'd hope the
white moderate would reject the myth
concerning time in relation to the
struggle for freedom
he says the teaching the an attitude
like like this that it's just going to
take a long time of gradual progress
stems from a tragic misconception of
time from the strangely rational notion
that there's something in the very flow
of time that will inevitably cure all
ills actually King says time itself is
neutral it can be used either
destructively or constructively more and
more I feel that the people of ill-will
have used time much more effectively
than have the people of goodwill
he also says at another point oppressed
people cannot remain oppressed forever
the yearning of freedom eventually
manifests itself and he goes on to say
human progress doesn't turn on wheels of
inevitability there is no sort of its
office automatically going to happen
what is it what does it take he says it
comes through the tireless efforts of
men willing to be co-workers with God
and without this hard work time itself
becomes an ally of the forces of social
stagnation so you know in response to
the people who are saying to look the
time isn't right for these sorts of
things I know that you're having a hard
life but you know can't you just wait a
little bit you know eventually things
are gonna change new generation will see
things differently and King says in
response to them the time is always
right all we always write from sorry to
do right it's always the right time to
make things better to make things the
way
they're supposed to be here he has a
interesting discussion as well about
extremism he's you know he's being
excused I'm being not excused being
accused of being an extremist yeah along
with them all the nonviolent protesters
he says look if you want to call me an
extremist that's fine because Jesus was
an extremist for love Amos was an
extremist for justice
Abraham Lincoln was an extremist in
saying this nation cannot survive half
they have slave and half free Thomas
Jefferson was an extremist saying we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal so then
King says the question is not whether
we're going to be extremists the
question is what kind of extremists were
going to be will we be extremists for
hate or for love
will we be extremists for the
preservation of injustice or the
extension of justice and so if we go
back to these categories again the
segregationist whites are extremists for
injustice King would say that those who
are in the african-american community
who are taking up the same sort of
tactics are also extremely for injustice
and for hatred these groups that are
going along with things they present
themselves as being moderates but
they're actually supporting the the
segregation regime they're going along
with extremism and they're being there
by extremists they've actually taken a
stand
while not seeming to take a stand so the
extremism to adopt is that of
non-violent action King reminds us that
privileged classes don't give up their
power they don't change the inequalities
unless people actually work to make them
do that so he's advocating changing the
situation of racism through this means